it's a former adviser to US President
Donald Trump has been sentenced to three
years and four months in prison Roger
stone was convicted last year of lying
to Congress witness tampering and
obstructing the investigation into
whether Trump's campaign colluded with
Russia
he's also been ordered to pay a fine of
twenty thousand dollars let's go live to
a White House correspondent Kimberly
Hulk it's for more on this Kimberly that
sentence that's been handed so much
shorter than the suggested sentence why
is this well it's certainly notable and
Judge Amy burn and Jackson did say that
she took both the initial recommendation
of seven to nine years as well as the
revised recommendation from Department
of Justice prosecutors into account
oh it's notable that she has struck a
sentence somewhere in the middle as you
pointed out there forty months or three
years four months as well as a 24 month
probation period and to $20,000 fine the
judge in this case had a lot to say
about how she came to her decision on
that sentence she said that Roger stone
has not been prosecuted for standing up
for President Trump but instead for
covering up for the president she
pointed to the fact that he had lied to
congressional investigators she said
when he said that he had no contact with
one of the witnesses she called that a
flat-out lie in fact noting that there
were documented up to 1500 texts and
emails of communication she also went on
to say that he brought this on himself
that he inserted himself smack into the
middle of one of the most incendiary
issues of the day namely the
investigation by robert muller into
whether or not Donald Trump's
presidential campaign had colluded with
Russia so she did take into account she
said a number of letters from his
friends and family who had requested
Lena's leniency but in the end she said
that there were many things that Roger
stone had done himself that she could
not ignore including
fact that he posted on Instagram a
picture of the judge next to a rifle
scope and crosshair assembly were just
there peacefully intolerable in the
administration of justice guess I'm also
watching the monitor as well as we
continue to talk and logistic be clear
that very last point I said was rather
important it was essentially that she
felt she had to make this sentence
because to not do so would be
intolerable to the administration of
justice this was a very angry judge as
she issued this sentence and as we watch
these pictures you can see there Roger
stone a lot of media interest about this
case getting into what looks like an SUV
with a lot of security this is a man who
has been at the heart of a lot of
controversy making serious allegations
against this judge as I pointed out not
only posting in social media but also
many of the supporters of President
Trump you really seeing him as as a
person who has been a victim of what
they say is a politically loaded case
they point to the fact that the judge
had been appointed by the former
Democratic president Barack Obama she
dismissed all of this and many of her
supporters in the legal community also
saying that when it comes to a sentence
it comes down to strict sentencing
guidelines and we see there Roger stone
driving away but that's not the end of
what we likely will hear from Roger
stone in fact there had been a gag order
in this case I believe it has been
lifted in fact the judge even saying
that she expects that Roger stone will
have more to say about this case she
said I expect he will keep talking
quotes Kimberly this has been it's been
quite a a case that has been quite
politicized shall we see perhaps because
of the connections Roger stone has to
the current US president he has of
course been reacting throughout the
trial and throughout this suggested
sentence being released and
has there been any reaction at all to
the sentence that's been handed down
from the White House you're absolutely
right when you say that Roger stones
connected he's been a friend of
President Trump
for more than three decades some 35
years in fact the President did weigh in
and that's what resulted in the initial
downgrading of the recommended sentence
the president called the recommended
sentence a miscarriage of justice that's
when the Attorney General had presumably
weighed in and the prosecutors came up
with a new sentencing recommendation
it appears the judge has gone somewhere
down the middle but the president has
been very vocal about this case in fact
one of the things he said this morning
in a tweet was they say Roger stone lied
to Congress oh I see so did Comey he's
referring to the former FBI director
James Comey he goes on to say FBI
exclamation point
fairness question mark what he's
insinuating is that everybody lies to
Congress and why is this bad and and not
for another individual so I expect that
the president may have something to say
about this he has been doing a bit of a
West Coast tour and we expect that he
may have something to say at a rally
when he speaks later on some hours from
now in Colorado but the bottom line is
the judge addressed the highly partisan
nature of this case saying that if Roger
stone goes unpunished it will not be a
victory for any one party she said in
the midst of all this everyone loses
okay Kimberly Hulk at their life
presence at the White House for know
thank you very much indeed at least so
just remind our viewers of who Roger
stone is and why he is so critical well
he's worked with Richard Nixon Ronald
Reagan George HW Bush and George W Bush
but it says rule in Donald Trump's
campaign which has landed him in courts
in the run-up to the 2016 election and
he tried to launch a smear campaign
against Hillary Clinton using the
website WikiLeaks he was questioned
about that last year during the Mueller
investigation and he lied threatens and
other witness to do the same and hid
documents from investigators in that
probe prosecutor said his crimes
warranted up to nine years in prison but
that says our hearing from Kimberly was
overruled by Attorney General William
Barr
shortly after tweets issued by President
Trump there all four prosecutors quits
after that decision
which many are calling a blatant
pressure from the White House
let's get more know from Claire
Finkelstein she's the faculty director
for the center of ethics and the rule of
law at the University of Pennsylvania
Law School good to have you with us
again on the news er let's take a look
at the sentence so far is it in line
with these kind of crimes do you think
justice has been served
well it's important to notice that the
sentence was 40 months which is smack
dab in the middle of the second
recommendation that the Justice
Department made namely the
recommendation that occurred after the
president tweeted and William bar
stepped in and required his prosecutors
to issue another sentencing memo their
recommendation was 37 to 46 months which
was a huge reduction from the sentence
that was originally presented by the
prosecutors and the judge in this case
said that she thought that the original
memos suggesting up to nine years in
prison
was really too harsh despite the fact
that she seemed to agree with all the
enhancing factors that increase the
sentence and was the basis for the
original recommendation the question
then is whether or not despite her
strong stance on this and the
willingness of this judge to stand up to
President Trump as seen by her sentence
of Paul Manafort whether or not she was
in fact influenced by the controversy
surrounding this case and the pressure
that the president has been putting on
both her and on the Justice Department
to be lenient with regard to his pal
Roger stone and will this is perhaps the
critical issue is it not that now nobody
can have confidence in whatever sentence
is handed down by this judge or it's any
judge I mean are we now to question the
motives of judges in the United States
well she's been a very fair and very law
and order judge after all what she did
in the face
of the pressure with regard to Paul
Manafort was incredibly brave she took a
lot of heat for it and she's been under
constant pressure from this
administration she also has a long
history of being a fair reliable and
very careful judge she gave a long
speech today explaining that her
sentence was not influenced by political
factors and she was very very strong in
rejecting both the president's behavior
and Roger stones behavior which really
went to the heart of the kind of
obstructive conduct that we see on a
regular basis from this president Roger
stone had in the very trial itself
ignored repeated orders from her for
example he ignored a gag order and in
the face of that gag order continued to
tweet about it he also attempted to
intimidate a witness by threatening to
kill his dog and this kind of behavior
really infects a trial and suggests that
if it's allowed to stand that it is not
possible to achieve justice so by taking
a strong stance against this kind of
obstruction she did score points for the
rule of law but the question is whether
or not the sentence was really harsh
enough to reflect the enhancements that
were validated by this kind of conduct
okay Claire Finkelstein great to get
your thoughts thank you so much for
joining us there from the University of
Pennsylvania Law School